Gidi for my little noah would it up so
let's go do some code vain it's
undeniably Souls like because it's
easier for me to talk about the few
things that it does differently than the
many things that it keeps the same as
always the key thing with these games is
how they innovate on top of the souls
formula for example Sultan's sanctuary
added platforming ayto promises a tiered
of loot system neo had fighting stances
and more of a sort of fighting game
flavor and loads of the Fallen
contributed code veins developers
believe that what this genre needs is an
AI companion and a revamped consumable
system but does it really need those
things how well do they work in the
souls framework well let's talk about
the companion system first in this demo
your AI companion is MIA
a bayonet wielding support character who
usually stays at range sometimes even
sacrificing her own health to heal you
and she's not your only choice of
companion I've read other articles that
say that there will be a diverse cast of
characters to choose from and that even
having a companion at all is optional
but the developers do hope that you'll
be drawn to these characters emotionally
which is kind of about as likely as a
berserk remake having good animation
there is hope though some voice lines
surprised me like this one where she
ribs me for exploring the same area
twice
aren't you or this line where she
informed me about the enemies below us
but let's take this idea a step further
and imagine if Mia could tell you that
she's going to take aggro from you or
that she just lost aggro and there's an
enemy coming your way imagine that she
was telling you that she's setting up a
trap or an ambush these sort of
contextual voice lines would put her
character on a whole nother level but as
it stands it feels a lot like playing
Souls with an NPC summon the entire time
and I mean you know exactly what that
feels like you always have to keep an
eye on them and devote a bit of your
concentration to what they're doing
whether they're dealing damage while
you're attacking the enemies or whether
they're tanking the enemies for you and
you need to peel the enemies off them to
keep them alive there's a wealth of
consideration here that you may or may
not want as a player and the challenge
that the developers are going to have to
overcome is making play with an AI
companion actually fun it's not an easy
task try and think of a game that was
actually made better by an AI companion
I'll wait at worst in code vain your
companion is getting in your way she's
not able to rez you because she's busy
with another animation or she just got
overwhelmed by a barrage of attacks and
died prematurely
however at its best code Vayne has you
and your companion healing one another
buffing one another and playing off each
other's strengths and weaknesses
if code Vayne really wants to set itself
apart it desperately needs to strengthen
these co-op mechanics for example I
would love the ability to direct my
companion on where to go or who to fight
there is a lot of potential here and
while it's frustrating at times I get
glimpses of this being a really really
fun way to play I just don't want them
to waste this opportunity as it stands
your only gameplay interactions with
your companion are through some of your
eco abilities which are active
with our - and displayed here you start
the level with ten points of ichor which
can be invested in a pool of eight gifts
now these gifts are based on your class
and there are several classes that can
be changed throughout the game so for
example with this character I can buff
my weapons I can buff my defense my
speed oh and you're gonna love this
trust me I can even go into super saiyan
mode with my partner if I use the full
ten points and by far the most
interesting way that I've seen this
system used is disability you can
resurrect or heal your partner by
sacrificing your health and they can do
it for you as well it is more if you're
low on icon or you want to increase your
maximum I call or eco or Iker I don't
anyway if you want to increase your max
you can go full anime and perform a
drain attack
draining an enemy of ICO is done by
holding X and charging your slash attack
it's done by parrying and reposting an
enemy or it's done by throwing them up
in the air while you're focused so
that's another mechanic I need to talk
about the focus mechanic when you get
hit in this game your focus bar here
increases and when it flashes blue your
abilities are enhanced your dodge is
faster your attacks seem more powerful
and you can even throw enemies in the
air for a drain attack which I just
mentioned and you know I don't really
agree with rewarding a player for
getting hit I think that's a bit weird
but what I do love is the icon and the
drain system if you're me in this video
and you're having trouble with the
[ __ ] third phase of this boss then
to make your character more powerful by
the time you reach the boss you can just
parry the world parry all the enemies
throughout the level and increase your
max iCore so that by the time the boss
fight comes around you'll be able to go
even further beyond I like that there's
a parrying system that doesn't just
reward you in the short term it rewards
you in the long term that's a really
cool thought it also rewards you for
actually fighting and carrying the
enemies in a level before a boss and not
just speedrunning the level and going
straight to the boss which is a problem
that I think Souls has to find a way to
deal with for the most part the combat
plays nicely and the developers do
deserve to be commended for most enemy
attacks actually being well telegraphed
and animated for the most part there
were some enemies that had absurdly fast
attacks and unrealistic AoE hitboxes
which often forced me to rely on my AI
companion or my six speed running skills
and did I mention how overpowered the
resurrection ability can be they thought
they could keep me off this ladder
hmmm everything in this game is anime as
[ __ ] except the ladder climb animation I
don't get it
once you're done killing Ryu for the
thousandth time you come across the
Queen's Knight which hey I can feel
myself getting tilted again just looking
at the footage compared to the rest of
the stage
the Queen's Knight is on another layer
of difficulty and as a result it really
exposes some of the glaring problems
with the mechanics in this build
first invincibility frames feel off
sometimes you really want to dodge but
your character is stuck in this really
stupidly slow recovery animation that
doesn't let you move just look at how
long this takes in addition the boss can
stun lock you into subsequent attacks
which never feels good in any game the
boss is fast I get that that's fine but
my character at least needs to be able
to respond to his speed the standard
recovery frames aren't fast enough and
the invincibility frames don't feel
right it kind of feels like fighting a
blood-borne boss with the Dark Souls
character next there are way too many
particle effects my body radiates blue
energy from me as buff and my sword
crackles with electricity I grow red as
I charge my heavy attack which is imbued
with extra power from my glowy revenant
super saiyan mode I sliced my opponent
and blood sprays out from his body as
Mia sends a red and yellow bolt of
healing energy my way sparks are flying
while we're clashing this whole time he
jumps into the air in a flash of black
and white coming down in a cloud of red
5 frames per second oh that's cool that
one shot me it's anime as [ __ ] but a key
part of anime is actually animation and
I can't see half the animations I
actually care about that's something
else they should fix to be honest the
fight is actually ok until round 3 which
is the bit that really rustled my
jimmies the only way I could beat him
was to burst him down in round 3 and not
care at all about my safety and just
rely on mia to manage her health correct
so that she could resurrect me over and
over again and just when I'm thinking
this is it this is the run yeah no
that's cool I'll get him next time
20% health he's at 10%
he's at 5% he's at 1% I'm about to lose
it
morning sunshine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]